alors mon raymond quel est ton problème
vas-y en fait voilà bon j'ai commencé
des pmp l'année dernière et ça fait des
rythmes de vie de tarés en fait c'est à
dire que je me lève à 4 heures 45 et je
me couche il est 23h minuit et je fais
ça parce que je me dis c'est une récré
donc je mets des sous de côté pour payer
la maison et pouvoir a laissé une maison
à mes deux enfants sauf les enfants quel
âge et ma fille et audrey qu'à 18 ans et
mon fils tristan qu'à 14 ans 14la ont
pas tarder à traiter tout seul on leur
baluchon si tu le vois donc si tu peux
accélérer les choses j'essaie
d'accélérer les choses sauf que là ça
devient infernal pas ce que je fais tes
pmp le soir le matin je dis vrai je
deviens vraiment fait vraiment vraiment
fatigué et ma question c'est est de vous
demander en fait parce que je me pose la
question depuis au moins deux trois mois
est-ce que je dois arrêter pmp ou est ce
que je dois arrêter le camion parce que
là je posais je me demande vraiment si
je dois continuer à livrer en fait alors
on devient très dur en fait mon chéri tu
sais que c'est joli c'est vrai qu'ils se
réveillent et 4h30 les
chauffeurs-livreurs dans quoi mon ami
dans les livraisons de boissons boisson
et café
bien sûr boissons donc tout ce qui est
déjà fait boissons
cacao bien leur donna au restaurant ma
part de chez toi qui as leurs parts chez
moi les 5h10 5h17 à 5 heures et ça c'est
pas possible en retard donc 5h10
et là tu va diriger et je fais ça depuis
juin 1992 sur une caresse dans cette
boîte et j'ai fait ça toute ma vie j'ai
fait que c'est toujours la même boîte
j'ai fait que ça a été non j'ai fait
deux boîtes à la terrasse et j'ai fait
deux boîtes mais c'est toujours ça a été
ma vie tout le temps en fait et tu te
réveille tous les matins 90 ouais donc
voila et donc tu pars à 5h10 de chez toi
là suivez toute la journée et le soir tu
ici s'arrête en forêt sont ouverts 14 15
heures je viens ici je prépare un peu
d'émissions et j'aurai le sais que tu
arrives ici donc tu arrives ici ils
arrivent ici à 15 heures pour mettre sa
chemise
il est prêt à 16 30
et donc voilà et donc raymond tu nous
demandes en fait si tu dois arrêter de
faire livreur cessa de quitter la boîte
ou tuer ou d'arrêter tpm pays c'est ça
que je demande en fait c'est parce que
je pourrais pas faire les deux je pense
pas fou je pourrais que je demande
l'avis de tout le monde et même les
téléspectateurs qui regardent et tu lui
donneras ton avis après et après la
décision que j'aurais sorti dans les
jours prochains
parce que ça devient laisser trop c'est
trop parce que c'est une belle émission
c'est une belle récré mais ça se
travaille un peu et c'est fatigant tu
peux pas te dire mon 400 ml toutes les
nuits mais j'étais surtout je conduis
cinq heures après derrière donc non mais
non mais c'est même dangereux
c'est vrai ouais voilà alors vous allez
donner votre avis les shérifs vous avez
donné dans un instant vous aussi on va
vous laisser le temps de réfléchir vous
allez nous donner dans un instant votre
avis sur raymond est ce que pensent et
qui continue ce qu'il doit on dit quoi
on pose comme question est ce que j'y
pense que je dois arrêter de faire du
chauffeur livreur à ce que je dois
arrêter les livraisons
d'accord on vous le demande merci vous
nous dites également ce que vous en
pensez
les cherry on aura et moi je te donnerai
également et c'est sérieux dans le
marais vraiment c'est pas ne s'est pas
une femme c'est vraiment sérieux c'est
une question de ça fait deux mois tout
l'été j'ai pensé à ça on s'est vu cet
été on a parlé pour éventuellement faire
que ça que tp c'est sérieux c'est pas en
mode heures ne fait pas d'eux pour vous
ne le faites pas pour jouer vous
écouterai vraiment on n'avait pas trop
vu la vanne
les autres il est compétent
[Applaudissements]
on avait un dilemme merci d'être avec
nous 19h11 je vous le dis à 20h10
pétantes
il y aura pour qui sera de retour ou qui
la peau cave qui a beaucoup beaucoup de
choses sur vous les chroniqueurs à la
tout observé faisant l'éloge ici autour
du plateau pendant les pubs l atout elle
sait tout ce qui se passe elle nous
donnera des infos il paraît que même moi
je suis visé au tlm a dans son
collimateur là pour le moment raymond
nous a posé une question vous a posé une
question chez vous à 19h11 en direct
vous savez il ya cette nouvelle séquence
qui s'appelle friend fun ce qui veut
dire et vous êtes ses amis oui vous êtes
les années aussi de raymond d une
famille et c'est vrai crémoux tous les
matins il se réveille à 4h30 du matin
par deux chez lui à 5h10 prend son
camion et il va livrer c'est ça mon
raymond il va livrer cafés et autres
boissons
il livre jusqu'à quelle heure vraiment
se dépensent pas je pars est à 13 30 14
comme je peux et jusqu'à 16 heures mais
c'est quand même une belle journée nous
a fait une petite boulette qui libre et
ensuite
[Applaudissements]
laugnac savoir c'est excellent excellent
os et donc raymond vous a posé une
question en question est-ce qu'il doit
continuer à être chauffeur livreur et
affaires tpm paix en même temps ou
est-ce qu'il doit arrêter un des deux en
fait la question est là reste à voir ici
il doit arrêter quoi ouaip avons ces
gouttes si on veut poser la question
arrêté et est indispensable alors dans
le cas de raymond je peux répondre non
pas maintenant que c'est incroyable je
voudrais on veut démarrer par une femme
car la galanterie c'est le plus
important ici fut très proche de réseau
vous savez très proche de votre mère
aussi si vous allez on y va je voudrais
la vie de valérie benalloul alors
raymond c'est une vraie question que tu
poses parce que c'est une question qui
est importante puisque tu as charge de
famille et donc effectivement ton
salaire est extrêmement important pour
la vie de famille pour ta maison je sais
que tu as des traites que pour tes
enfants qui sont encore à l'école etc
je t'aurais dit si cette émission et si
ce n'était pas une émission avec cyril
hanouna je t'aurais dit bartabas
non non je t'aurais dit continue le
métier de livreur oui parce que la télé
parce que la télé c'est un métier
extrêmement éphémère et tout peut
s'arrêter du jour au lendemain et c'est
pas une source de revenus fiable c'est à
dire qu'on peut effectivement gagner de
l'argent et puis pendant plusieurs
années ne plus en avoir et connaître des
cycles très très difficile parlement
pour l'année prochaine mais mais il
s'agit de cyril et cyril est un garçon
qui a plein de fausses à sevrey ouais
mais une qualité que personne ne pourra
lui enlever
c'est que quand il aime quelqu'un et
quand ils décident de faire un bout de
chemin avec cette personne il fait le
bout de chemin jusqu'au bout du chemin
et il ne te laissera donc jamais tomber
donc peu importe la vie qui l'aura est
ce qu'il va faire et c'est qu'ils
deviennent patrons de chaînes ou pas je
ne sais pas il emmènera toujours dans
ses bagages et donc je pense que si tu
décides est d'arrêter le métier de
chauffeur livreur d'abord un sale touche
jamais nommé bagages juste sur un truc
s'il arrive à battre la suisse une au
genre
elle toucherait infiniment d'abord parce
que tu aurais pris un choix qui est un
choix risqué et donc ça voudrait dire
que tu lui fait infiniment confiance et
il ne trahira jamais cette confiance
donc moi pour moi tu peux arrêter le
métier de chauffeur livreur tu peux
arrêter le cd v vers un autre avion va
prendre à la vie la vie de la sagesse 1
allez géraldine alors et géraldine
exactement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors aimons moi je te trouve absolument
excellent autour de la table c'est une
bouffée d'air frais mais je pense que tu
as bouffée d'air frais elle vient aussi
de par son métier c'est à dire que tu le
dis c'est vraiment aussi un regard sur
le monde un regard sur la télé et c'est
ce qui fait que tu es totalement
singulier autour de cette table et c'est
à particularités et moi je pense que la
parenthèse tu le dis c'est souvent ici
la récré la parenthèse mais une
parenthèse sassou mais ça peut aussi se
refermer et moi je crois que justement
la télé c'est quelque chose de très
fragile
ça peut à tout moment dépendant du désir
des autres donc même si évidemment syrie
les fidèles le désir malgré tout peu
changer on ne sait pas ce qui peut
arriver
alors moi je trouverais plus tôt enfin
je trouvais que ce serait une bonne idée
que tu es en sorte d' emploi du temps
aménagé falloir que tu puisse venir deux
fois par semaine à tpm paix c'est tout
pas plus parce quand je dis que
physiquement c'est éprouvant tu n'en
peut plus et ça je peux tellement le
comprendre et le reste du temps que tu
te concentres sur les gens qui désirent
épuisé un doc gynéco seront les rôles
dans la vue oui les tons vrai métier il
faut que c'est moi je pense qu'il faut
que tu gardes ton vrai métier parce que
c'est aussi ce qui tourne adn en fait
adapté je suis très partagé parce que
comme le dit géraldine c'est un peu ce
qui fait ton personnage ta force ta
personnalité en tant que chroniqueur t/t
celui qui représente le mieux les
téléspectateurs les français et c'est
vrai que le sol autour de la table à
avoir ce métier à l'avoir gardé et c'est
quand même que ça fait quand même partie
de ta vie depuis plus de 26 ans presque
presque 30 en italie est toujours bien
[Rires]
dans la vie dans la vie d'un homme c'est
énorme c'est une vraie carrière et je
pense que tourner la page tu peux tu
peux c'est pas une décision que tu
pourras prendre assez facilement je
pense que tu devrais arrêter artel le
week-end par contre juste une question à
trévé j'ai l'impression après tu me
répondras tout à l'heure j'ai raison
viser la lune ça ne te fait pas peur
mais tu me réponds bah alors castaldi ne
t'ont fait comme ça
oui en tête chez vous alors moi je sais
pour avoir le même millénium je savais
que vous entendez moi je pense que ce
qui fait toute légalité sur le plateau
même si tu es plus tous les matins
sceaux d'anjou dans son camion tueur a
toujours ses qualités tués en plus en
phase avec la vie tu connais la vie et
était dans le temps
à l'été ce qui est pas forcément le cas
de tout le monde sur le bateau et m'a
évidemment dedans je me mets dedans
voilà d'accord mais je vous n'êtes vous
êtes en dehors des réalités padoue louis
parent mais oui mais si la vois pas ce
que lui quand il voit un camion pour lui
c'est une smart
[Applaudissements]
c'est un playmobil
donc on s'entend très bien et je pense
que que tu as ta place évidemment dans
l'émission tous les jours contrairement
à ce que dit gérad et je pense que tu es
un vrai plus pour l'émission et je pense
que pour vivre pleinement laventure bas
c'est vrai pardon et jour il un jour sur
deux mais je pense que pour vivre
pleinement cette belle aventure de
télévision je pense que tu peux mettre
de côté le ton boulot que tu retrouveras
forcément plus tard parce
qu'effectivement c'est pas sûr bah oui
parce qu'il a des qualités parce qu'il a
moins de 6 ans d'expérience autant
autant la télé ça peut s'arrêter autant
sur métier je pense qu'il peut le
retrouver je pense que quand on est dans
une équipe comme ça de tpp je resterai
avec nous et en plus tu vas à mon avis
encore plus profiter de tout ce qu'on
vit ces ensembles alors on avait
complètement aucun autre à la vie voilà
de quelqu'un qui découvre la vie mais
quelqu'un qui est le plus frais ici
c'est vrai vous regarde vous êtes comme
un ananas
c'est vrai vraiment on vous ouvre sais
pas ce qu'on va trouver pour ça que
c'est une vraie question c'est vrai
qu'en télévision personnes et est
remplaçable
ça on le sait tout dépend en réalité de
la nature de ton contrat si tu viens un
deux trois quatre jours question bien
oui mais c'est vrai je savais qu'on
avait dire vous savez c'est comme à la
drass et passive est pour
[Applaudissements]
l'ananas il est tout bois cate a été
dégoûté et bat lui c'est pareil
lupo têtu par équipes et des boîtiers la
flambée alors rien que pour vous et au
delà de tout ça aurais tu vas tu
resteras la base ouvert la porte de
cette émission et c'est moi qui dois
vers la porte a justement c'était une
manière de parler et on côté vraiment
extérieur ton oeil extérieur et qui
apporte à l'émission donc s'il était on
ne peut plus aller qu'elle y reste
merci kenya alors beaucoup de saison il
a beaucoup de saison je viens d'entendre
benjamin et lorsque maxime ça non mais
avant martine aubry alors oui à l'examen
j'ai l'air d'autant de benjamin et je me
dis qu'il a pas il a pas si tort c'est
qu'en fait je me dis que tu as un cv de
fou ça fait 30 ans que dans son
entreprise moi et c'est impossible qu
après tu ne puisse pas trouver de
travail
moi je pense surtout à ta famille c'est
que tu as des enfants et ils ont besoin
de toi même à l'est encore plus à cet
âge là ce cas après midi bios pas ils
vont barrer
mais le truc c'est que la main ils ont
besoin de toi et je me dis que oui et un
instant à le faire pour moi ce serait
tpm paix parce que ton travail tu le
trouveras toutes à vie parce que tu es
enfant tu es moche que je trouve trop
toujours besoin de toi je pourrais vous
seriez je trouve qu'ils ont besoin de
toi on finira par jean michel thierry
pour moi lumière d'allumer la lumière
exactement c'est un réverbère ça que les
chiens l'adorent isabelle moi ça doit
être la contagion je suis d'accord avec
ce qu'a dit géraldine parce que tous à
la galerie chagall la riche et oui aussi
la richesse de de raymond c'est ce qu'il
voit sur le terrain régulière et nour et
les missions des anecdotes qu'il a vu
sur le terrain et je trouve que c'est
dommage de se couper de ça c'est une
vraie réalité nous populaire il pas fait
de la pression ou les ménages moi je
suis effectivement pour la ménager mes
frères en direction
la ministre de la justice à l'époque je
suis pour l'aménagement sur la tête de
ma mère jerry kelly un truc 12 oui mais
bon là mais les bouchons sinon ça gérer
ouais bien sûr l'hiver c'est fatigant
pour madame et où il faut choisir et il
faut choisir on n'est pas ici ou là on
dirait bien d'une ariane doit sauf un
qui sera le soir dans tpm d'affairé de à
ses pas et qu'il y va mais moi je suis
pas les juges mais je suis pas une
grande saison mais sans rigoler mais un
conte comme idée mais tu conduis tout
seul toit ouais je vous hais elle
faisait interpeller d'ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tout s'était joué des attentions
je suis admiratif de ce que fait rire
c'est autant dans une journée dont on ne
savait pas comment y bosser autant dans
une ville placée en moi bien règles pour
l'expert en tout cas je te félicite
parce que rien obtenir ce que tu as fait
c'est déjà énorme
alors alors voila mais si on la choisira
évidemment je suis comme david benjamin
choisi la télévision
voilà c'est une aventure qui est
merveilleux la th la téloche là je
dénigre pas du tout métier de chauffeur
livreur est enfin là tu vis des choses
que tu vivras jamais dans une autre vie
franchement moi ça a bouleversé ma vie
toi tu adores ça tu le vis aux puces a
permis de pécho donc franchement est
marié à mechelle virtuellement salsa
secteur des banques
et puis c'est quoi il ne fait rien il
est fidèle jamais mais avec le souci
d'être de ma vie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le gall et on se battra douze autres a
dit merci les chéris avant qu'on voit la
vie des téléspectateurs dont je vais
vous donner mon avis et après raymond tu
va nous dire la décision qu'a prise que
va prendre une décision ce soir
pourquoi je déjà pense que tu es tu as
beaucoup d'avenir en télévision et pmp
c'est une émission mine de rien voilà
dans laquelle on sait que ça va pas
s'arrêter dans une semaine dans deux
semaines à moins que castaldi ou
jean-michel 10 une grosse bêtise à
l'antenne
vous voyez on arrive à gérer les choses
mais elles entendues mais je pense que
la télé et même la radio parce que les
mots coûterait d'appels tél c'est vrai
que tu un vrai personnage
maintenant j'ai un peu comme géraldine
et agathe et isabelle d'ailleurs merci
oui bah les trois drôles de dames l'un
d'ailleurs libération merci donc c'est
vrai que tu te nourrit également de ce
que tu vois plein de ici c'est vrai
qu'on aime bien tes expériences savoir
tu parle avec beaucoup de gens nous
aussi mais tirait que toi tu croises
beaucoup plus de gens dans la journée de
parts on travaille donc tu as aussi le
ressenti de certaines personnes sur
telle émission sur tel sujet donc c'est
vrai que ça te permet de te nourrir
aussi voilà de ce que pensent les gens
et ça c'est hyper important pour nous
après mine de rien ton patron et a fait
confiance depuis combien d'années
maintenant celui que j'avais avant ses
20 ans cela six ans voilà donc c'est
vrai que c'est les gens qui ont été
d'une extrême fidélité avec toi je pense
qu'ils ont besoin de toi il ne rien
aujourd'hui que trouver quelqu'un de ta
compétence ça va être compliqué pour eux
donc moi ça me fait toujours un peu de
peine de laisser les gars qui t'ont
donné aussi ta chance ils ont permis
aujourd'hui de construire le personnage
que tu es de construire aussi de pouvoir
faire vivre sa famille pendant toutes
ces années donc c'est vrai que moi
j'aime pas quand on laisse tomber
voilà que vous savez quand il ya des
gens qui partent ici je suis toujours un
petit peu énervé parce que on leur a
donné leur chance et c'est après je veux
bien qu'ils grandissent mais c'est vrai
que c'est toujours un peu compliqué donc
je le comprends et je comprendrais
qu'ils sont un peu fâchés parce que
c'est vrai que tu as donné ta chance et
tu
depuis mai dans cette boîte depuis
maintenant tu me disant mais il est
content il est content de ce que je fais
est content il ça ne dérange pas que tu
vas contraire et alors mais je sais
qu'aujourd'hui si tu dois choisir
quelque chose je pense aujourd'hui que
je suis comme eux je pense que tu dois
choisir touche pas à mon poste
la télé la radio et continuer à
s'épanouir voilà dans dans ce domaine là
et dans le domaine des médias
mais voilà après c'est vrai que dans ce
domaine là tout peut s'arrêter du jour
au lendemain même si on sait jamais hein
voilà même si benhaim disait voilà on
est moi je suis peut-être on sait jamais
peut-être que je vais me faire virer
c'est ma dernière année de contrat on
sais pas peut-être que je serai viré en
fin de saison est forcément si vous
voulez venir à la maison c'était
bienvenu mais puissance 4 jokari mais
malheureusement je ne pourrai pas
te dédommager pour le jeu de local alors
mon chéri mois donc ma décision c'est
que je pense quand même que tu devrais
rester en télévision si tu dois faire un
choix en tout cas tu as un coup à jouer
voilà au niveau médiatique parce que
time vrai t'as une vraie singularité et
ça c'est important c'est ce qu'ont été
les vous avez tous ici une singularité
regarder castaldi voilà on le sait on
comprend rien de ce qu'il dit ce qu'il
dit c'est sympa mais naim oms et voilà
que benhaim voilà elle aime les gens
voilà jean michel maire on sait jamais
s'il va pouvoir terminer une phrase et
c'est sympa maxime dénis baupin maxime
d'aidé matching ai dit c'est la cour des
miracles en fait ça c'est comme ça qu'on
aime c'est ce qu'on aime on a une
personne voilà qui concerne aussi plus
anti plus elle n'a pas dormi depuis 120
ans
vous avez plus de 6000 vote sur cette
action on va voir la vie et
téléspectateurs j'ai ma petite idée
quand même parce que je sens que tu es
très ému tpm et donc qu'est ce qui vous
motive choisir entre lille et le psg je
croyais que ça allait plus tranché que
ça ces besoins sont absentes et mpm 36%
livraison c'est bon sur les 36 % qui ont
voté livraisons il ya 90% de chauffeur
livreur qui alors raymond ta décision
c'est ta décision
j'étais belle phrase ah ouais moi ça
fait s'il choisit la librairie par tout
de suite là où il faut
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors les mots compliqués on a besoin de
savoir maintenant
quoique si vous avez raté mais c'est
pourtant la décision grâce à une
décision prise à ce stade c'est toute sa
vie et vous dire quoi ni quoi que j'ai
fait à 8 heures d'émission la wii doit
faire ils doivent choisir maintenant et
mon ton choix il est simple où tu me dis
oui cyril je dois rester dans tpm pays
s'affrontent à trois choix où tu me dis
oui tu ta question que je pose avant
avant que tu donnes tout choix
sais tu veux absolument prendre une
décision tu peux plus de tâter haute est
au bout du rouleau goûter au bout de ta
ville sera pas utilisée durant les 2 et
c'était dur les deux très dur et le
problème des décès les problèmes des
ouvriers c'est qu'ils ont peur du vide
on a peur du vide on a peur de garder le
peu qu'on a c'est pas comme vous vous
êtes des aventuriers j'ai un respect
pour vous tous les aventuriers mais non
même si une évidence à la maladie je
hais les jeunes maxime mais c'est des
aventuriers parce qu'ils partent à vias
sur des contrats d'un an
un ouvrier quand il a un cd il est
content grande chez lui il pose sur la
table dit les amis j'ai un cdi
donc c'est difficile à prendre comme
décision ouais c'est sûr on aimerait
tellement pouvoir me lever à 8 heures le
matin préparer l'émission tranquillement
a dit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bosser chez vous j'aimerais bien le
vanuatu matin pour préparer au mieux son
recul et mollo mollo l'écho là c'était
pas bon c'est pas bon port donc on va
prendre tu veux prendre une décision je
dis moi tu peux pas faire les deux c'est
sa part les deux ça devient je les fais
l'année dernière j'étais rincé cet été
j'ai réfléchi
là j'ai refait encore échu c'est pareil
je te sens alors je te le dis je t'adore
dis moi mais c'est vrai que parfois je
me sens fatigué il sait pas les mêmes
pratiques que doc gynéco la dernière
j'étais n'agira défi non mais c'est vrai
raymond va pas se mentir
l'année dernière je m'étais limite on
board out à la raison parce que quand tu
es fatigué sur les dernières volet nike
souris sur les nerfs la des nerveux en
ville des vérités intrus s'est tu et
comme tu es tout comme à cannes on te
touche public n'a été épuisés alors
raymond mon chéri est ce que tu veux
continuer à être chauffeur livreur et
moi je n'en voudrai jamais et si un jour
tu veux revenir tu sais que la porte
sera toujours ouverte qu'à ce stade il y
voit que des portes ouvertes mais pour
toi elle sera grande ouverte
ou bien tu me dis oui je préfèrerais
rester dans tpm pays et je suis me dira
comment ça s'est passé avec avec ton
patron parce que tu va nous raconter
aussi l'entretien avec lui parce que
forcément je pense qu'il va être un
petit peu déçu de perdre face l'as d'or
voilà nous regardent nature à vous adore
non je pense pas qu'ils regardent mais
il m'adore ça s'appelle comment
s'appelle comment ou alors il s'appelle
monsieur tout comment meciar que tout
monsieur arc tout ils ratent pas devin
mon directeur monsieur a reconnu ce
monde dirait un blaze d'échoppés à des
jeux olympiques on a une chance de
médailles ont fait chacun avec un peu
noir que tout ça rigolait il a répondu à
la question je fais tes pmp c'est ben
laden en bresse le sûr que tout julian à
un séjour remo tu le rates un imposant
d'un statut spécial raymond je me posais
une question il ya un instant aux gens
rappelle aux téléspectateurs qu'ils nous
rejoignent
raymond est chauffeur livreur et en plus
il est dans touche pas à mon pote il se
réveille à 88 du matin ils partent de
chez lui à 5h10 à 5h20 il a déjà livré
trois cacolac il livre des boissons
voilà et raymonde un peu plus rémois
étaient pratiquement là dix ans en
burn-out l'an dernier et je pose la
question est-ce qu'il doit être que
chauffeur livreur ou est-ce qu'il doit
être que dans tpm p que doit-il arrêtez
vous a posé la question on va revoir la
réponse aux sondages
qu'est ce que raymond doit choisir entre
tpm pays son travail de chauffeur
livreur 65 35
voilà donc vous êtes deux tiers à penser
qu'il doit continuer tes pmp et un tiers
à penser qu'il doit continuer son
travail de chauffeur livreur il a été
chauffeur livreur pendant combien
d'années vraiment des 26 ans 26 ans jean
à 92 ch à entrer mais toi ces dernières
caristes vous avez quel âge 27 mai il
avoue à l'énerver vous avez livré la
ville à gaza
non mais c'est ouf en une vie voilà un
autre en compte vous rendez compte
s'avérer la vida gâte c'est un film
magnifique on dirait les gars pas un
fumeux la ville de ghardaïa à et de
raymond échos bercy calmer vos tubes
vraiment quel est votre décision
voilà parce que tous les téléspectateurs
l'attendent
nous aussi d'ailleurs vous venez je ne
connais pas la décision de raymond
personne ne la connaît ici je demandais
pas ma pub de ne te le diras personnel
ya eu plus de onze mille tweets
c'est beaucoup réagir sainement et pour
voter sur cette décision qui est
importante pour vous mais qui est
importante également pour les
téléspectateurs parce que on sait que
les téléspectateurs de tpm paix vous
apprécie énormément
et quand vous n'étiez pas lent début de
saison combien de messages
combien de twitch e-reçu disons oui
raymond est d'abord j'en profite pour
les remercier parce que quoi des fois
j'ai des grosses tournées que c'est dur
et qui flottent et que je suis dans la
rue en train sous la flotte est comme un
chien mouillé je regarde les messages
temps en temps et ça fait plaisir donc
je voudrais remercier tous les gens sur
twitter qui me laisse des messages sympa
voilà je vous embrasse
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais aimé qu'on est de 3 réactions
voilà de twitter de trois personnes
voilà mes deux trois tweets mais
apparemment la régie est déjà rentré mon
on t'écoute est vraiment moi ta décision
est importante pour moi également
et pas seulement pour l'argent c'est
yann a envie de vouloir faire tes pmp à
fond d'être opposé mais de dire je vais
arrêter de bosser
la peur du vide en fait c'est plus je
pense que c'est ça c'est la peur du vide
je vais je vais en parler demain avec
mon patron je voir ce qu'il en pense
mais je pense que je vais continuer tpm
t
[Applaudissements]
c'est notamment pourquoi en fait
explique nous parce que son père est mûr
ouais parce que parce qu'il ya plein de
choses qui m'arrivent il ya des plaintes
et il ya aussi je m'éclate en radio
aussi je fais un bisou à la radio aussi
à christian ollivier qui est qui m'a qui
m'a donné la chance de pouvoir parler
fou de pouvoir parler football à la
radio parce que le football c'est ma
passion était plus un paiement menée sur
ça tu m'a emmené sur ça tu m'emm n'est
fait ça à expliquer aux gens que j'étais
pas un maire de citer qui avait arrêté
l'école à 15 ans et gens mouraient les
gens m'ont dit ah bah finalement ce que
tu dis on va écouter alors que toute ma
vie on n'a jamais écouté je peux pas
faire connaître nos matous temps dit et
le maire de citer
donc voilà pour ça merci j'ai envie moi
de m'impliquer à fond comme les
camarades travailler les émissions c'est
pas c'est pas un bon exemple
voilà loos le matin ils ont les sujets
regarde les replays ge
moi j'ai du mal à regarder les replays
seront dirigés pas beaucoup de temps
hors du mal aussi pour d'autres et donc
voilà je vais avec mon patron
demain si on peut trouver un arrangement
qu'est ce qu'on pourra faire et ce que
je ne peux pas prendre un nom il ya
quelqu'un toujours twitter qui nous
propose un nom de congé sabbatique mais
faut voir avec lui s'il est d'accord un
an ou six mois il le découvre à
l'antenne au canada s'ils regardent il
va le découvrir sur moi l'antenne on en
a parlé m'a dit c'est bien ce qui
t'arrive c'est génial ce qui est dingue
at on pas trop ça veut dire c'est bien
il dit que c'est bien mon patron patron
de disney à la patronne dit pareil dit
que ces merveilleuses qui t'arrive c'est
une belle aventure c'est c'est bien donc
voilà battus par les avais je vais en
parler avec lui voir si on peut pas
trouver un truc et puis si on peut pas
trouver un truc c'est en tout cas moi je
veux tu veux te remercie et je veux
remercier tous les camarades pour ce que
vous avez dit sur moi ça fait plaisir je
remercie les gens du public les césar
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai c'est ce qu'a toujours le mot
juste
[Applaudissements]
tu en as très fort mois son patron parce
que vraiment voilà voilà dû payer de
gros bisous et il est franchement c'est
beau ce qu'il dit parce que voilà qu'un
pad il faut que t'arrêtes à un moment
j'ai caplongue patron quitte aurait dit
je te le dis ouais arrête avec tes
conneries de la télé tu vois c'est ça tu
sais moi le premier alors j'aime
beaucoup l'art c'est bon je laime je
l'aimais beaucoup mais là c'est qui est
marrant pas du tout